scritte dal pai col nostro punto di
vista è quello di cambiare punto di
vista cioè di guardare con gli oggetti
che spesso sono destinati alla discarica
ad essere sotto il radio quegli oggetti
dei quali non sappiamo più cosa facile
abbiamo trovato un nuovo punto di vista
un punto di vista di rigenerati dalla
nuova vita come come ad esempio alcuni
di questi strumenti così presidente lo
felicemente potremmo trovare in uno
strumento con delle vecchie tavole da
stiro dei vecchi tubi di plastica e una
tavolata volatore quelle che si sono per
i cantieri che è diventata uno stilo fa
non c'è un balafon uno strumento a
percussione che prende ispirazione
tradizione africana ma con le materie
prime che troviamo alla fine turno
adesso è purtroppo le nostre materie
prime sono propri rifiuti e quindi
guardando il rifiuto da un altro punto
di vista diventa appunto un punto di
ispirazione per le nostre creazioni tra
poco sentirete punto il palaforum oppure
un altro strumento che è un vecchio
barometro dall'orologio che
e diventato in questo caso una chitarra
slide oppure abbiamo fatti lardo che è
diventato un passo lato tra l'altro
funzionato da uno dei pochi musicisti al
mondo che non ha fatto il conservatorio
bensì la vennero personali
ci sono tracce di ciauscolo dice andrea
proprio ancora si sente dall'inter
oppure anche altri oggetti che ne so
questo vecchio phone che è diventato un
microfono per parlare o altri oggetti
con i quali suoneremo il nostro
repertorio dei nostri bimbi come ad
esempio lo spremiagrumi scrivendo in me
è uno dei nuovi rifiuti no troviamo
questi rifiuti elettronici
lo spiega noi abbiamo scoperto che ha un
potenziale tratto di ogni spremeva non
esistente fa una nota una nota meno
decisa soul con la quale poi ci
arrangiamo in quella tonalità i nostri
pezzi si ci avviciniamo alle tonalità
degli uccelli gli oggetti ci ispirano
forme strumenti anche suoni quindi la
prossima canzone e parte proprio con lo
spread i toni e alla quale speriamo
anche il coinvolgimento diciamo no
questa divisione tra paio col pubblico
ma riunione tra l'altro se volete potete
partecipare alla canzone che sta per
iniziare dicendo una parola suonatelo
perché il nostro notte non buttatevi
avanti anzi suonatelo emettere canteremo
neal avrete un volo
dovete dire suonatelo per facilitare
quando faccio così facciamo una prova le
dobbiamo non buttatevi a me niente 4
voti alla quarta volta dove dovete di
teheran che lo facevano finta che la
quarta volta non buttate via ma niente
anzi il pubblico migliore di oggi
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ecco andrea aveva un sogno del cassetto
che a quello di suonare la chitarra però
purtroppo non avendo i soldi e preso
direttamente il cassetto ci ha fatto la
cassetta era eccoci qua
[Musica]
ci sono mai sentiti
niente
ogni oggetto abbandonato
schiacciata c'è una storia quell'oggetto
che perde
[Musica]
no
suonate
[Musica]
si no
sì suonati
[Musica]
rcd
dopo di iscrizione
[Musica]
sbaglio il meccanismo
quello del seicento
c'era
siamo uniti
e successo che ci aspetta
[Musica]
bene
condizionate
[Musica]
e nuove
per la bottiglia che significa però di
un certo che di assistere
[Musica]
potere svago bene musica
sono
suonatelo grazie
avevo montato meno mi presentano mai
sempre il penultimo mi lasciano e questa
specie di batteria che dialetto nostro
marchigiano chiamiamo il bidone della
spazzatura lo chiamiamo buzzico o buzzo
a jesi è diventata la pizzeria
poi siccome tutta blu è diventata dalla
blu seria e tre marie oggetti che ci
sono abbiamo fatto per esempio urlante
con il metodo africano il tiraggio che
ci ha insegnato caio che è un albero
fondamentalmente ve lo vedete bianco ma
in realtà dal senegal è fatto con le
lastre agx che ormai non ce le fanno più
ci danno solo itc p
ma noi abbiamo tutte le lastre di tutti
gli aussie che si sono rotti i nostri
amici negli ultimi dieci anni potremmo
farne per altri dieci anni di strumenti
ma uno della parte da parte di un
importante che utilizziamo soprattutto
nella pizzeria la russia e la plastica
come ben sapete è il problema più sta
andando di moda tra virgolette lo dico
così perché ormai da molto tempo noi
affrontiamo questo vogliamo del gruppo
di lavoratori ma è fondamentalmente se
il futuro ci saranno degli archeologi
che studieranno questa è ovviamente la
chiameranno
l'astice le perché siamo a una
produzione di plastica che è diventata
in l'incredibile pensate che
probabilmente nel 2050 se continuiamo di
questo passo senza recuperare il peso
della plastica ci sarà nell'acqua sarà
maggiore del peso dei pesci che ci
vivono
quindi adibite a dio la spigola l'orata
perché mangeremo cavallette e coccinelle
probabilmente perché sta distruggendo
ogni parte del mondo abbiamo fatto
diverse cose con questa plastica
sapete esiste il pvc e il pet il pet e
la plastica e si usa soprattutto per
alimenti e abbiamo fatto diverse
tipologie come ad esempio abbiamo
scoperto che la plastica con il colore
si riesce si ritira e quindi diventa
molto più acuto il suolo che produce per
poterla e riusciamo a creare gli
strumenti come questo che paghiamo lo
scudetto vero che si chiama spring
splendida ram
lo faccio sentire
gli effetto effetti speciali o che
sentirete poi si vedranno anche altri
strumenti come il timpano fatto con la
bottiglia dell'acqua che trovate nelle
sala d'attesa negli uffici e abbiamo
trovato scoperto questo metodo dal
brasile el abbiamo applicato perché lo
scambio di conoscenza per noi è
fondamentale
mi hanno fatto anche un urlante con lo
stesso modo è la stessa plastica
scaldata ed ecco che noi la plastica la
chiamiamo la pelle perché per noi le
solite dei belli ne sto 20 ma dai
rifiuti che tutti conosciamo
oltre legati a quelli della l'appunto la
plastica quant'altro ci sono dei rifiuti
molto importanti che non sono tangibili
ma che sono notizie notizie false
così si conciliano di cui andiamo in
giro ne parliamo al bar perché abbiamo
letto su un qualche una qualsiasi pagina
facebook con queste notizie si chiamano
caio perché è un po in grotta la chiama
fake news
ma noi chiamiamo bufali e famosissime
può fare abbiamo deciso di fare proprio
un brano legato questo argomento le
bufale e si intitola mozzarelle di
bufale ecco andrea suonarlo ombrellino
elettrico che con l'ombrello
dell'utilizzo fatto come una corda e una
elettrica ovviamente e buon ascolto
[Applauso]
[Musica]
non è un animale successo finale
le chimiche come lisci e invece lo
disegnano righe quale posso che colui
liquami
i nostri pensieri
[Musica]
male
risponde rimanere
[Musica]
bocciare di fare
gente sembrano cerchi magici se c'è dai
ceti più il 13 5 la testa centro di luce
c'è chi ancora
e aggiunge dopo centro di cuori
non proprio che è divenuto il termine o
che sia di falsi miti dei partiti
le frasi di operai
[Musica]
oggi
[Applauso]
[Musica]
lo dirà mai
ok
[Musica]
velocissimo e che sentiamo vi salutiamo
concludiamo questa questa nostra
performance b con voi con elastici su
scatola di mozzarelle di bufale abbiamo
felicissimo queste bufale e michele caio
tiberi che questo clico all'ananas sulla
testa sta cercando di montare lo
strumento con tre corde accordatore è
una cosa che ci vuole tipo dieci minuti
macario ci rimetterà tre secondi
accordarlo tre note tra gli elastici una
nota per ogni elastico e apparato lui
potete imparare potuti mila è giusto
caio la
[Musica]
l'elastico tende a scordarsi vai anche
facilità accordare a checa l'intento di
rivolgersi a casa non è che gli
strumenti anche perché le scatole di
quel tipo si trovano davvero ai volti
delle strane 1 minuto e 40 abbiamo quel
che succede succede poi controlliamo
[Musica]
fiori in questo momento c'è un
personaggio che ti dà qualcosa di
particolare attenzione attenzione
213 o sua madre comuni queste tattiche
gratuito
o
[Musica]
no
non dico di vivere
voi
[Musica]
[Applauso]
così